just went to the cardinals this is a big
move uh-huh who's the best d-line now in
the division you already know that
question bro well you have been knowing
that question bro
about consistency dawg
what the rams been putting out no
appreciate myself but we all know who
the real nine-nine is that's all that's
right that's right
that's michael brocker's walking through
an airport speaking to tmz recently we
know who the real nine-nine is and he's
referring to his teammate aaron donald
not j.j watt and not marshall goldberg
either aaron donald the real nine-nine
in the division so that raises the
question sharing let's let's
ask this question with all due respect
to j.j watt who's a hall of famer
three-time defensive player of the year
how many nfc west
defensive players would you take right
now
over jj watt let's begin with the rams
there are two that stand out and and i
think we'll stipulate aaron donald
jaylen ramsey either guy we'd take over
jj watt is anyone else on that defense
you take over j.j watt
well you know i like leonard floyd he
had a big year he had a better year
frankly than j.j watt did and michael
brocker so i'd have to think about those
two but i think they rank right up there
with jj watt if not better than jj white
i mean this was mike the number one
overall defense in the nfl they were
good and they're the reason they won the
initial playoff game it had nothing to
do with jared goff it had everything to
do with that defense against the
seahawks so i love this defense and and
so i would probably take that defensive
line over the cardinals defensive line
so i might throw those two guys in there
at least with jj watt if not better than
j.j watt
floyd one of four defensive starters for
the rams scheduled for free agency next
week a lot of pass rushers a surprising
number of them eligible to become free
agents on march 9. seahawks who would
you say on that defense is better than
j.j white i think we can agree on jamal
adams who would you add be on that list
yeah shortlist i would add baby bobby
wagner because i i think he's still
playing at that elite level he's going
to go the hall of fame too i think we
sometimes forget about him those are the
only two guys on that dna we know how
bad that defense was last season they
were 32nd in in the league for most the
season for much of the season they
played better in the second half of the
season but i would put bobby wagner
right now to this day as being better
than j.j watt over his course of his
career yeah i'm giving j.j watt but
right now i think i'm ranking bobby
wagner above jj watt mike
seahawks another team with four
defensive starters headed for free
agency led by kj wright who
if he was under contract you could make
the argument maybe he is at or past j.j
watts level right now
uh that would be something on which
reasonable minds possibly could differ
all right let's go san francisco 49ers
yes nick bosa
beyond bosa yeah who would we put on
that list
even bozo with the injury i think you
got fred warner right i mean aaron
rodgers called him the best linebacker
in football it's really hard to argue
with that i'd certainly put him on there
and and i said if if the 49ers are going
to make a trade with with anybody for a
quarterback if they get into sean watson
conversation if i'm houston i want i
want him i want fred warner on my team
and i'm demanding him in that trade it's
going to hurt to get him so he's a guy i
would want to trade for you know d ford
and solomon thomas both were hurt early
last season dford played one game
solomon thomas played two games perhaps
if they hadn't been hurt early last year
and we're coming off those injuries mike
i might throw them in there but they are
coming off injuries so i probably
wouldn't throw them in there i'd
probably just say nick boson fred warner
i agree with you on
warner and boasts uh eric armstead could
make a case for it he got the big
contract
after the trade of deforest buckner last
year because they realized they couldn't
pay both of them solomon thomas due to
become a free agent we talk about bud
dupree all the time coming off of
tourney ciel and becoming a free agent
solomon thomas in the same boat four
other 49ers defensive starters they have
five all together yes four plus one is
five uh jason verret jakovsky tart
richard sherman and dante johnson all
becoming free agents in uh just nine
days all right the arizona cardinals the
team for which jj watt will play
chandler jones better than jj who else
on that defense would you say you'd
rather have than j.j
what i'd go buddha baker mike i think
he's outstanding one of the best
safeties in the league and i think he
proved it to [ __ ] this year so both of
those guys and i think chandler jones
right now in his career is better than
jj white a couple years ago when he had
the huge year i voted for him for
defensive player of the year the
cardinals weren't very good but i just
thought he dominated i thought he was
fantastic and that probably will make jj
watt a better player but right now today
chandler jones even with his injury is
is the better pass rusher
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports